just for context we were doing revenues
of around 300 pounds a day
online prior to that event everything
was handmade after
after the event we turned the website
back online and in the first half an
hour of the website being live we sold
30 000 pound in product
as a youngster i was too honest i was
very quiet
i just sort of got on got on with it i
didn't particularly enjoy school but i
wasn't a nuisance i wasn't like
a naughty kid or whatever i sort of
did it because i had to but because of
my gcses i didn't get the best grades
my mom essentially marched me back to
school and just says right you are gonna
you are gonna work incredibly hard and
you're gonna get good grades now
and she really sort of like fought for
me because the school originally didn't
actually want me to come back
and she essentially persuaded them to
take me back on for another couple of
years which was
brilliant i was let back into school
under the under the agreement that i did
the
essentially the the um subjects that
were given to me i did
business studies which i did okay at um
and it
which was like a huge pivotal moment for
me was how well can i develop websites
or you know build different things
um and for me that was completely game
changing so i absolutely fell in love
with that and i did
you know incredibly well which was a
brilliant moment for me because i hadn't
particularly done well in academia
before that
so you start university and you're doing
um business what was university life
university live for me was was
essentially i it was it was very
functional i went into aston in the day
i do my lectures i'd normally finish
those lectures about four or five
o'clock
i then go from there to peak to her and
i do my shift which would normally
normally be from
five till ten half ten by the time
you've cleaned up i had
massive freedom because i'd if i was in
if i was in the um the restaurant i
could essentially
i'd get a free pizza for every shift
which was brilliant i would be pot
washing if i was in the restaurant and
if i wasn't i'd be out
obviously delivering the pizza in which
case i could mess around on my phone in
between
you know in in between deliveries i
could read stuff or by the time i'd
started gymshark i could respond to
customer queries
in between my deliveries which was
perfect for me so let's
talk about starting jim shark
going back to 2011 2012 or even before
that when i was sort of growing up
massively into bodybuilding
everything that he was looking at was it
was over the pond we were looking at
americans for the most part we were
watching american youtubers
body power just conveniently enough was
20 minutes away from where i lived so it
was at the birmingham nec which was just
a huge strike of luck for me um but it
was that one time of year when you could
go in and these people
the lifters the fitness i guess stars
would come into birmingham for one
weekend a year and you could physically
see them talk to them meet them do like
all of that and that was just something
i'd never experienced before
in 2010 2011 i think i was visiting the
expo
just as a bit of a fan after the 2012
event i went
home and i was chatting to my mom and my
nan who um now to sew and so on
and it was that made me think right i'm
going to buy a sewing machine and a
screen printer at the time
and sort of make make the product myself
and to be honest the gymshark website
was because i'd never made a website in
fitness that would transact so it
wouldn't sell things
so it was it was more of a
like a test almost like previously i
would test myself could i make
an app that would do this and then i
wanted to do it could i do and
create an iphone app that would do that
and then i managed to do it then it was
all these different things and this was
just me making a website that would
transact
and i just had this sort of innate gut
feeling that we needed to be at this
event i had no idea how much it costed
what it would look like what would we do
how we would have enough product to sell
i just wanted to be there
so i essentially walked up to the
the show organizing they had like a
small booth near the entry
and i just said next year i just would
like a stand here whatever your cheapest
stand is
i want i want this stand and i'll never
forget it was
three thousand it was three thousand
pounds i didn't have three thousand
pound at the time
like i'd never seen three thousand
pounds so it was a bit of a
i guess it was a bit of a leap to sort
of say or i guess agree to have that
um but it was definitely one of the best
decisions i've ever made
so because everything was handmade we
turned the website off
a few days before the event so no one
could get their hands on the product so
i think a lot of people that were
getting on the website
probably couldn't get their hands on it
so anyone local or even in the uk was
going to make their way to the event
so we sort of accidentally created
scarcity
we also kept the website off for that
weekend we
we launched a product for the event so
we we took the product there and we
launched it at the event which also
wasn't available online tease that on
facebook because at the time that was
that was the only
social platform that we had as well as
youtube
and we brought our heroes to the event
people that we idolized and had fired
for years and those people were
youtubers
um or now as people call them
influencers
i'm sort of there unloading stuff out of
the van it's probably probably 30 yards
away from the lorry loader to the
other the loading bay to the to the
stand as i'm walking over to the stand
with the box i'm seeing a
flood like hundreds and hundreds of
people flooding straight from the nec
entrances to the gymshark stand and
you know at first in that moment you
think this can't actually be true i
can't believe that this is actually
going on
are they you know are they going to go
past the stand i was thinking of every
sort of
reason as to why this is nothing to do
with us but
literally floods of people were there to
see gymshark the brand
sort of inadvertently went viral whilst
having this sort of scarcity and demand
all of that combined with the fact that
no one else was making product for the
the true lifter the bodybuilder after
the event
we would just we would lay on the floor
in the sand completely just like
we were absolutely knackered hadn't
slept all that weekend we just weren't
non-stop
um and like someone sort of wandered
over from a big big big brand
and they just said like how the hell did
you do that and
the only thing that we could say back to
them was i've got no idea
i honestly it was just i was just
shell-shocked just for context we were
doing revenues of around 300 pounds a
day
online prior to that event everything
was handmade
um after that event we completely sold
out of everything
at the event i was i was sat in my in my
parents living room and it was like
i don't know midnight one o'clock in the
morning i actually flicked the website
back on and in the first half an hour of
the website being live we sold
30 000 pound in product so i'm sat in
the pitch black downstairs in the living
room
just having had this insane sort of half
an hour sales period
i'd been scrambling at my laptop to turn
the stock off because at the time every
single product was set to infinite stock
because there was never any chance of
selling out of it so to go from 300 quid
a day to 30 000 pound in half an hour
everything good sold out it was um it
was absolutely mind-blowing
it was like living a dream i'd never
experienced anything like it and i
there was never a point where i thought
it would ever happen
i quit pizza hut i think it was shortly
after that
we'd i remember it was around the period
where we broke a 250 000 in revenue
which was a obviously a momentous
occasion it was brilliant
and pizza hut was brilliant for me
because one it was a job i enjoyed
i learned a lot doing it and i had the
flexibility to do gymshark in between
deliveries
but not only that the money that i
earned from pizza allowed me to you know
to live and it meant that every penny
that jim sharp made
would be reinvested into the business
for you know the first few years of its
life
and that was um that was absolutely
brilliant and it helped the business
grow so so much
so yeah it was a big leap because at the
same time as leaving pizza hut i left
university
and albeit that didn't actually make a
massive difference in to me financially
um emotionally that was an interesting
decision because i'd worked
so hard to get there like like i said i
was not
and i'm not naturally an academic person
or i don't
i don't think i am i'd given everything
to get into university and ultimately i
did it because i wanted to make my
parents proud because they'd worked so
hard for me
however the second i told them that i'd
made the decision and i said this is the
decision and i'm going with it
there was not one time ever they brought
it up again
after i've made the decision they
completely and utterly backed me and i i
think that made a massive difference as
well
what would you say was the the best
decision you made
in the early days of the company so when
you start a business
you have to have a very very clear
vision about where
you want the business to be and the
likelihood is that will be somewhere
where people
won't have seen or been before so i'd
characterize my role at gymshark at the
time is i had to
grab the business by the scruff of the
neck and drag it to where i thought was
right
regardless of what anyone would say and
there were so many people that would say
you want to get your product into
different retail stores you need to do
this or you need to do that and i had to
be the person that would say no
this is my vision and we're going to
carry it there by hook or by crook
now as soon as then the business gets to
a certain stage
arrogance and i guess that sort of
dragging the business mentality just
isn't the right thing to do because you
have to then surround yourself with
brilliant people people that are better
than you that can help grow the
individual aspects of the business in a
in a scalable way
that was incredibly incredibly difficult
for me i had to learn to trust people
which was equally difficult because the
business was my absolute baby
i'd been involved in every single facet
of it and all of a sudden i had to
realize that i can't be involved in
every single facet of it and i had to
learn to build great teams
what has been the pro your single
proudest moment
so when gymshark started i was your
typical
pizza typical 19 18 year old lad i was
working at pizza i was on the four pound
90 i think it was an hour and fast
forward to today
you know there's 550 staff we've got
offices in
london in the midlands which we're
building a big a large campus there
we've got offices in hong kong in
mauritius in denver colorado
um this calendar year
will have sold over half a billion
dollars worth of product
which is again crazy and just to be
clear as well
half a billion dollars worth of product
only through our website this isn't like
we have hundreds of stores around the
world
and that's a mind-blowing um
level to get to so the company's now
been valued over a billion
pounds when that moment happened how did
you feel
it really hit me when i was driving home
um
what we'd achieved there was this just
moment of
um just it sort of hit me as to what
we'd achieved um
and it didn't last long to be honest
because the second i started thinking
about like sentimentally about what
we've achieved in my mind to jump back
to the first
screen print the sew in um the events
the risks the moments of
the highs and the lows it all just hit
me in that moment and
it was a really it was an amazing
feeling
and i had that moment of just i guess
joy um
and excitement that deal had been done
in a way where we were always looking
forward as to what we could be and go on
to be which you're starting to see now
building a business you know valued over
a billion was just something i never
thought that we would do
several years ago i was far more
arrogant far more
like pig-headed i i didn't listen to
other people in the way that i would
know i didn't
take things on board partly because i
was just
more immature but partly because it's
what i felt and was probably right for
the business at the time whereas now
i'd say i listen a lot more and i've
managed to
i guess develop myself throughout the
years
what advice would you give to the next
fan francis
it's it's so easy to look at jim shark
in isolation that this thing that blew
up and did incredibly well but people
forget about the seven
websites and the four apps that were
produced beforehand which failed
miserably and the reason jim sharp can
exist and has done what it's done today
is because of those prior failures
failures will allow you to succeed so i
think people need to reframe they think
about failures
and just give it a go go all in on
something and see what happens and you
know what
if it doesn't go well then that's cool
you can always try something new
i walked from directly from the stage
to this i remember sitting on this sofa
in like the reception area
and just started getting this like
about these palpitations i remember
saying to myself like oh this is it this
is where you die